[Music]
hey guys here's gameplay of dishonored
death of the outsiders second chapter
follow the ink we play through the
chapters main objective along with the
game's new optional contracts all the
while showing off Billy's awesome new
powers and gear if you want to know our
thoughts on the game check out Lucy and
Tamar's hands on impressions video and
make sure to sub so you don't miss our
full review when the game comes out in a
few weeks thanks for watching when I
first caught sight of doubt I was just a
broken kid stayin alive out of spite he
cut the throats of three men without
making a sound
leaving only blood and death in his wake
I don't know what I was hoping for when
I followed him that night
but he shared his strange magic with me
and more than that his skill his time
his trust and sometimes his secrets now
he's not the man he was here in his
final days he's got wounds that won't
ever heal and regrets as sharp as mine I
know how much that carves you up inside
but I found him and he wants me to help
him make up for a lifetime of sins by
killing a god the Abbey teaches us that
the outsider preys on weakness that the
void is the source of doubt heresy and
suffering
that the outsider is to blame for all
our ills
who knows maybe they're right
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the rich pay to poison themselves with
this [ __ ] which they just finished the
job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's smell what are they mixing these
inks with
[Music]
this must be where the eyeless get inked
I always wanted to join a cult alright
if this is what it takes
don't flinch
Shawn Yun the singer and a city
administrator Ivan Jacobi these are high
profile people there's a third leader
mentioned but no name
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
people put up notices over here if
you're interested in making screenings I
serve with discretion take a look around
the prices reflect the exquisite quality
of the items offered
[Music]
no need to wrap it from the suppose
[Music]
farewell and do think of us again I miss
my old cigar shop smell of tobacco I had
two nice to see you again
[Music]
[Music]
not even the dead get any rest in car
naka
[Music]
: plaza huh I should pay Ivan Jacoby a
visit
[Music]
what you're not your face
that was lunch make sure that trap door
stays closed don't want to fall through
in the middle of my speech you heard mr.
Jacoby close the damn trap door already
yes
citizens of Karnataka I'm here to to
demand the repeal of the reappropriation
of abandoned burials and grave sites act
the braving disrespects the deceased and
change the living would you want your
loved ones to
disrespect and shamed craving
disrespects the deceased and shames I
think I have it citizens of naka we're
here today to speak for those whose
voices are gone from us every time we
destroy a grave and erased a name from
our cemeteries a silent scream resounds
through the void which you want your
loved ones know I should stop
their shroud
everyone sympathetic mood
that joke about the false teeth whiskey
the knocker at the winter semester now
thinking citizens of the dead are being
moved the wandering spirits are watching
of citizens of Carnac gonna scare the
audience citizens of Karnataka
one do that
[Music]
[Music]
that's it let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hopefully they'll just leave me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these people are sick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I bet my last corn it's gonna be Brian
hagfish Kanaka cuz that the latest news
from around the aisles
[Music]
I keep mine in mind I'm like duty so
what I forget is out there
that's how would you know what a full
day's work looks like
keep him quiet he won't go snooping
around asking questions about Jacoby and
the cienfuegos a murder after a little
chat we should have snapped off a few
fingers to be sure can't type with
bloody stumps next time if our reporter
friend doesn't wise up fast you can make
his neck a bloody stump well never mind
[Music]
if I have to be stopped
[Music]
some iowa's goons tried to persuade me
to stop the Cienfuegos investigation I
must be onto something big what
investigation karnak has had a string of
gruesome murders all the blood drained
from victims while they're still alive
ivan Jacobi's involved somehow I know it
but I need evidence I'm offering a
reward for anyone who can bring me proof
of his involvement
here's your proof you were right it was
Jacobi he seems to have unusual hobbies
I knew it
those monsters Ivan Jacobi my friend
you're going down
the combination is for to to help
yourself
what I wouldn't give to see my new
bosses on hello what's going on
was coming from here
I know
[Music]
hear them talk
[Music]
[Music]
last coin is gonna be Brian hagfish
again gotta dry that Elevens our teacher
it's good and still no matter what you
might want to rinse that foul mouth of
hers too
[Music]
and shops and to report any vagrants
beggar or vendor in the area to the
upper Syria district independent
householders Commission
[Music]
what's the holdup I was supposed to
interview Shan Mian hours ago
[Music]
man help you with something
yes a drink Let Me In The Spectre is a
private club are you a member right here
see
Elena's work get sloppy nevertheless you
may
[Music]
[Music]
what can I do
[Music]
what do you have there flushing the
temps tonight so there's no whale but
we've got whisky Romney plague spirit
for air so uh if you're staying sober do
you have any house specialties maybe
you've heard of the sin when infusion
but the private lounge upstairs is
booked for the next month you'll have to
come back another time if you wanna
triumph
whiskey sounds good whiskey it is the
shipment of dunwall finest alive just
yesterday
since it's your first time at the
specter you should definitely try the
sanguine infusion it's the house
specialty aren't you what is it whiskey
some sort of potion is it like plague
spirit what do you ask
actually I'm gay and these bull rats you
twit
but you know nothing so far
[Music]
[Music]
what do they want
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have the relic that's all that
matters they say it's secured new secret
flexible past the infusion is flowing
brace
it's ourselves the factotum said that
tonight's vintage should be savored
strictly for connoisseurs he said the
outsider will walk with us tonight I
feel it singing through my veins
oh the exquisite pain the veiled parts
we're already crossing over but our
dalam us he gonna die hey I hate it when
they linger I much prefer a hasty 1000
laps at me like the ocean itself it's
not like black nails clawing at my
stomach
you can't leave troubled car
you must be from some other ethnicity
you missed your chance what a shame
[Music]
now they'll know what it's like on the
other side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on different but they'll
still recognize me from the posters best
avoid them if I can